there are so many new Beauty releases
happening all the time so we gathered
some of the most hyped products to test
for ourselves this month I tested out a
lot of products from Simi Hayes Beauty
this is a new brand for me so let's
start with the stuff I liked the solar
tint blush duo comes with the cheek
pigment and a cheek gloss these both
went on really easily and the pigment is
so good surprisingly I love the cheek
gloss more even though it's not super
practical for all-day wear I didn't love
the color of this velvet blur matte lip
balm on my skin tone but the formula
itself was so good it has the comfort of
a lip balm but the pigment and blurring
effect of a matte lipstick it's creamy
and super comfortable I thought the
lunar lip gel and the super slick mini
lip balm were just okay the lip gel was
pretty but the formula was nothing
special it's just a thin lip gloss the
mini lip balm was pretty moisturizing
and the tint is cute but it's so little
product for what you pay again nothing
special now for the products I just did
didn't like I wanted to love the sun
flush all over face tint but it just
ended up being really patchy and broke
up my foundation and I tried this a few
different ways to see if I was just
applying it wrong but it still messed up
my Foundation underneath the easy lash
clean lift mascara just didn't do much
for my lashes I didn't get much lift I
got little to no volume and my lashes
weren't lengthened very much overall I
love the packaging of this brand and it
does have some standout products but I
think it's all very overpriced for how
the actual formulas perform everyone has
been raving about the summer Friday's
Lip Butter bombs this set with the minis
is limited edition but they sell all of
these Shades in full size I ended up
really enjoying these the formula is on
the thicker side but not sticky they
feel really moisturizing and I like how
they give an almost lip gloss effect I
loved all of the tinted bombs but I
think poppy was my favorite they all
give a pretty subtle wash of color and
they have this nice vanilla scent that's
not overpowering I'm obsessed with these
this is the danessa myrick's beauty
lightwork 4 Transcendence palette I'm
not gonna lie I was very intimidated by
this palette at first it has four
different formulas velvet chromes which
are color shifting powders pressed
Chrome flakes which are flaky Toppers
glass metallics which are Super
reflective powders and aqua chromes
which are water activated duochrome
pigments so there is a lot going on I
started applying over a light wash of
black eyeshadow base to make the colors
pop more but I don't even think I needed
to do that because these powders are so
pigmented I was determined to use all of
the different formulas so I added one of
the metallics in the inner corners and
put the Chrome flakes in the center the
flakes were the only formula that was a
little difficult to work with only
because they're kind of hard to pick up
and apply but I think they added a
really cool texture and color shift to
the eye look I used an aqua Chrome for
some eyeliner and it's so reflective and
sparkly and it dried down quickly this
palette is Extreme really pricey and I
did get some slight Fallout but the
quality is definitely there and I think
it's so much more versatile than it
seems the shades in here are so
transformative and really inspire you to
play with your makeup plus it can also
be used on the face these are the
L'Oreal color reach intense volume matte
lipsticks I thought these were going to
be similar to the Nars power matte
lipstick I tried a while ago but the
formula is different the color payoff on
these is so good and they apply really
smoothly this is one of the most
comfortable matte formulas I've ever
tried especially from the drugstore what
makes this lipstick different from the
Nars one is that it's unfortunately not
transfer proof to be fair it claims to
be smudge proof so it's not the same
thing regardless I think these lipsticks
are comfortable on the lips and the
colors are so rich so I really like them
apparently Gwen Stefani has her own
Beauty brand called give and this is the
first product from it that I've ever
tried this is the double dip in two in
one lip color remover and hydrating lip
mask I wanted to test it out with my
Nars power matte lipstick since it's one
of my hardest to remove lipsticks the
formula of this lip mask feels like a
makeup removing cleansing balm if you've
never tried one they feel really oily
because of that it actually broke the
lipstick down really well it made it
super easy to remove however as a
regular lip mask it just feels way too
oily and thin to be comfortable this
just feels like one of those products
that they Market as multi-use to make it
sound more Innovative light slacker just
released its winter collection called
cocktail hour I do own a lot of their
polishes so this isn't a new brand for
me but I definitely think this is my
favorite color story they've ever done
the polishes have those wide flat
brushes I love for applying it just
makes it so much easier and faster I
tried the cream shades old money and
Audrey first and both were full coverage
into coats and the application was
really smooth then I tried the jelly
shade called lady in red because this is
a jelly it's way more sheer than a cream
so I ended up doing two thicker coats
for full color payoff the color is
slightly lighter on my nails than in the
bottle but still pretty and so shiny
next I tried to the nines which is a
metallic polish I really love this color
but this formula is probably the least
forgiving when it comes to streaks and
Bubbles my two absolute favorite Shades
from The Collection are whiskey neat and
diamonds are forever whiskey knee is
also a metallic formula but it's more of
a duochrome and diamonds are forever is
like a Milky taupe with a bunch of super
fine glitter in it I don't think these
colors separately are anything new but I
love how they all work together in this
collection and the formulas are all so
good
all right